[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans filecho pour
ce premier numéro de la rentrée on
s'intéresse aux centres commerciaux ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux sur notre
territoire et face à la concurrence ils
doivent se réinventer constamment comme
ici à l'espace Saint-Quentin qui fête
cette année c'est 25 ans nous ferons
aussi un point sur les chiffres du
chômage notre première invité est Hervé
deot bonjour bonjour vous êtes directeur
de l'espace Saint-Quentin et de Sky West
l'espace Saint-Quentin qui fête cette
année ses 25 ans et qui donc va être
complètement rénové à hauteur de 6
millions d'euros c'est pour faire face à
cette concurrence absolument le centre
commercial comme vous l'avez dit fait
ses 25 ans donc forcément il a il avait
vécu et ils on on se doit de le remettre
au goût du jour on va traiter les
extérieurs et l'intérieur du centre
commercial pour lui donner voilà une
autre atmosphère pour faire toujours
plaisir à nos clients alors la
concurrence est est vraiment proche de
nous on pense à part l' 2 et vézyi qui
sont aussi en rénovation et puis à Alpha
Park 2 aux clés sous-bois qui vient
d'être inauguré comment est-ce qu'on se
démarque constamment pour attirer
toujours une clientèle et fidéliser ses
clients aussi un centre commercial c'est
déjà les enseignes donc en fait il faut
renouveler ses enseignes renouveler les
concepts on sait qu'un concept ça dure 3
4 ans donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
absolument tout le temps réinvestir et
forcer les enseignes à bouger et aussi
offrir des services pour accueillir la
de la meilleure façon de la clientèle
alors quelle est la clientèle ici à
l'espace saint-quenttin on a une
clientèle familiale et aussi une
clientèle de de jeunes on a accueilli
euh la faculté de médecine il y a 2
jours donc 3000 personnes et étudiants
qui fréquentent sur le centre commercial
donc c'est une nouvelle cible en fait à
conquérir oui ils sont déjà captifs mais
voilà on les a accueilliis on leur a
proposé de découvrir notre offre avec un
petit Welcome Pack et euh on essaie de
de les choyer et qui a le réflexe de
venir chez nous alors outre les
étudiants il y a aussi de nombreux
bureaux aux alentours comment conquérir
cette clientèle de salariés et bien en
fait on s'adresse on veut vraiment
cibler leur faire des services
spécifiques alors à côté de l'espace
Saint-Quentin il y a aussi Skywest qui
va bientôt être complètement rénové hein
pour un concept assez nouveau c'est de
l'outl de luxe oui tout à fait en fait
nous allons rénover deux niveaux du
centre commercial de Sky West garder le
cinéma et renforcer la zone restauration
pour comme vous le disiez en fait offrir
quelque chose qui n'existe pas dans
l'Ouest parisien c'est-à-dire
des magasins de luxe à - 30 % sur les
collections de l'année passée alors qui
n'existe pas encore mais encore une fois
au clés sousbois un autre centre
commercial est en train de sortir de
terre qui s'appelle The West et qui qui
se positionne sur le même créneau
écoutez oui pour sur le papier
maintenant je connais pas vraiment leur
projet parce que ils ont repris la
parole pour pour redimensionner moi je
peux vous parler de carré privé et nous
on est vraiment sur ce secteur là on a
un savoir-faire avec nos partenaires
Codic pour aller cibler ces ces
enseignes de luxe alors l'espace
Saint-Quentin vous disiez une clientèle
plutôt familiale on va aller chercher
les étudiants et puis les salariés et
puis à côté le futur carré privé ouest
qui est plutôt tourner vers le luxe des
services peut-être VIP comment faire
cohabiter ces deux concepts et bien
justement en fait on va pouvoir offrir
un un un panel complet de de ce que peut
offrir la la consommation euh
c'est-à-dire que vous allez pouvoir vous
faire plaisir sur le carré privé en
achetant des accessoires ou euh quelque
chose de haut de gamme mais quand même
après serrer et puis venir faire aux
achats je dirais du quotidien sur
l'espace sa-quentin alors on parlait
tout à l'heure des clés sous-bois et
d'Alpha parc 2 qui vient d'être inauguré
on va aller faire un petit tour de ce
côté-là et voir de quelle manière les
promoteurs ont su innover pour
accueillir une nouvelle
clientèle 75 millions d'euros
d'investissement pour réaliser ce centre
commercial tourné vers l'écologie c'est
10 % de plus que pour une version
classique et 15 ans d'amortissement
nécessaire avec le plus grand murs
végétal du monde des jardins et un
parking vert l'extension d'alphaark 1
aux clés sous-bois mise sur une
clientèle familiale l'immobilier
commercial pendant des années c'était
des des des boîtes à chaussures en
bardage pourri qui défiguraient les
entrées de ville nous avons nous décidé
de de de d'investir dans le
développement durable nous avons décidé
d'investir dans la qualité car nous
pensons que les clients à l'époque du
commerce électronique vont continuer à
venir dans des centres commerciaux mais
dans lequel ils vont trouver un plaisir
qui un plaisir de se promener un plaisir
d'aller faire du loisir une are de
pique-nique des restaurants et des
activités de bowling et de karting sont
proposées face à une concurrence féroce
le choix du développement durable et du
loisir s'est imposé il faut savoir
innover en permanence pour apporter au
client bah ce qu'il souhaitent ou ce qu'
ce qu'il ne sait pas encore qu'il
souhaite en fait les premiers clients
étaient attendus mercredi matin
accueillis par des salariés recrutés le
plus souvent localement au total 700
emplois avec le la première phase de
d'alphaarc qui sont qui ont été destinés
en priorité bien sûr au au cléiens
puisque donc nous avons même organisé
des recrutements à l'intérieur de la
ville tout près d'ici un autre centre
commercial est en train de sortir de
terre positionné sur l'outlet de luxe il
devrait permettre la création d'une
centaine
[Musique]
d'emplois nous voici donc devant ce mur
végétalisé à avec Philippe journau
bonjour bonjour vous êtes PDG de la
compagnie de falsburg qui gère et
investit dans plusieurs projets
commerciaux à travers la France et
notamment au clés sous-bois alors on est
en pleine crise économique et pourtant
vous avez investi dans ce nouveau centre
commercial alors nous avons démarré ce
projet bien avant la crise puisque nous
inaugurons ce soir alpha Park 2 qui est
la suite et la fin de Alpha Park 1 que
nous avions inauguré en 2006 donc c la
fait 10 ans que nous travaillons sur ce
projet euh nous l'avons démarré en 2002
et ce soir c'est c'est l'aboutissement
puisque nous l'inaugurons et nous
l'ouvrons dès demain en fait et donc
malgré la conjoncture vous êtes
confiants nous sommes tout à fait
confiants parce que Alpha Park 1 marche
très très bien les clients se
reconnaissent dans la qualité que nous
avons mise dans alpha Park 1 nous avons
essayé de faire encore mieux dans alpha
parc 2 avec de grands espace végétalisé
avec le mur végétal le plus grand du
monde c'est une vraie plusvalue ce mur
1500 m² de surface pas loin de 2000 pas
loin de 2000 m² c'est le plus grand du
monde et c'est la preuve que nous avons
voulu investir dans la qualité parce
qu'aujourd'hui crise économique ou pas
crise économique les gens cherchent à
être considérés ils cherchent de la
qualité et il cherche aussi de
l'écologie et le meilleur moyen que nous
avons trouvé c'était effectivement de
demander à une star internationale qui
est Patrick Blanc qui a réalisé le mur
du du musée du kbranli de réaliser ce
mur à l'entrée de ville d'clés sous-bois
et il est CIN fois plus grand que celui
du kbranli et alors de quelle manière
comptez-vous attirer les clients
c'est-à-dire cet aspect écologique peut
faire venir plus de monde ce qui ce qui
va attirer les clients c'est la qualité
des enceignes que nous avons ici sur
Alpha Park la proximité du grand plaisir
à côté euh aujourd'hui il y avait
boulanger il y avait cultura il y avait
Castorama il y aura maintenant alinéa il
y aura le plus grand magasin maison du
monde euh de France combien de marques
vont être présentes alors nous ouvrons
une vingtaine de magasins et de marques
en plus des 15 qui existaient déjà dans
alpha parc 1 donc ça fait 35 surfaces
alpha par 2 finalise un petit peu cette
grande zone commerciale qui démarre au
clés sous-bois qui se termine à plaisir
et dans lequel vous avez Ikea vous avez
auchamp vous avez toysus donc c'est
vraiment une offre qui est fantastique
sur pour la région parisienne que nous
trouvons ici quel est le profil de vos
clients et vous tablez sur quelle
clientèle quel combien de clients alors
le profil de nos clients ce sont les
consommateurs qui ont besoin de
s'équiper en équipement de la maison
mais aussi les gens qui ont envie de
passer un petit peu de temps en famille
qui ont envie de de passer une
après-midi parce que nous avons un speed
par qui est un centre de loisirs nous
avons une salle de sport nous avons une
place gourmande ici avec H restaurants
nous avons une air de pique-enque gratu
donc ce sont les consommateurs du 78
tout cela a un
coût rien n rien n'est trop beau pour
nos clients alors l'investissement pour
75 millions d'euros c'est c'est c'est un
investissement important par rapport aux
autres projets que vous menez c'est un
investissement très important et c'est
un investissement courageux en période
de crise économique vous l'avez dit mais
nous avons pensé que
que ça le méritait et puis et puis nous
sommes très très heureux de l'avoir fait
sur combien d'années allez-vous amortir
cet investissement 15 ans pendant 15 ans
nous ne gagnerons pas d'argent et au
bout de 15 ans nous espérons gagner de
l'argent alors tout près d'ici un autre
centre commercial est en train de se
construire qui est sur un autre créneau
l'outlet de luxe qui devrait ouvrir dans
quelques mois c'est un autre créneau on
vient de le dire mais c'est encore un
centre commercial alors est-ce qu'à un
moment donné l'offre ne va pas dépasser
la demande tout ce qui crée de
l'attractivité pour les clés sous bois
est bon pour nous donc nous considérons
que tous les gens qui vont venir à the
West qui est juste un peu plus loin sur
la route vont passer devant alpha Park
et donc vont voir l'offre qui alpha Park
et qui sera qui est évidemment une offre
qui est différente et qui est
complémentaire à celle de the West et
vice-va donc si vous voulez the West va
nous renforcer va et donc nous n'avons
aucune crainte sur le fait que cela va
contribuer à la montée en puissance de
d'Alpha par et des clés sous-bois alors
alpha Park 2 sera inauguré très
prochainement 350 emplois vont être
créés est-ce qu'il y a encore des postes
à pourvoir alors tous les magasins ont
quasiment fini le recrutement en
revanche nous savons que les
restaurateurs cherchent encore des
collaborateurs donc c'est plutôt vers la
restauration que l'on va pouvoir trouver
des emplois puisque alinéa donc a
finalisé ses recrutements maison du
monde c'est la même chose donc c'est
plutôt vers les restaurateur qu'il faut
se diriger merci beaucoup Philippe
journau merci à vous et pendant qu'on
parle de l'emploi les chiffres se sont
envolés fin juillet puisque le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi a franchi la barre
des 3 millions dans toute la France les
Yvelines sont un peu mieux lottis
puisque l'augmentation n'est que de 1,2
% comparé à l'augmentation nationale qui
est de 1,4 % on décrypte ces chiffres
avec Dominique de grise directeur de
Pôle emploi dans les
ivelines le volume d'inscription sur les
les tris derniers mois fin juillet c'est
plus 12 % et plus 12 % c'est quelque
chose qu'on voit très très rarement
vraiment c'est une situation avec des
situations sur les les inscriptions qui
sont principalement causées par des
arrêts de mission fin de CDD fin
d'intérim des des population qui ne sont
pas renouvelé ou qui n'intègrent pas des
CDI au même niveau que que ce qui é qui
existait avant on voit une croissance
significative de la demande d'emploi
senior alors qu'il faut relativiser
parce qu'il y a eu quelques éléments en
terme de de toilettages statistiques qui
font qu'ils sont plus comptabilisés
maintenant qu'ils ne l'était avant mais
on est quand même sur des croissances à
deux chiffres et ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'on est plus maintenant dans la
réalité de ce qui est le fonctionnement
du marché de l'emploi avec des
difficultés importantes euh plus
importantes pour ces populations de
retour à l'emploi on a eu une
augmentation de de la demande d'emploi
des jeunes très significative sur le
mois de sur le mois de juillet euh on
est à plus 3 + 3 % alors que la
population globale ne crois que de 1,2
donc on a vraiment un effet un effet
important sur la population jeune deux
raisons à ça c'est que c'est les
premières populations qui se retrouve
dans les CDD dans lesémissions d'intérim
les premières populations qui vont être
concernées par cette croissance des
premières entrées et puis on était aussi
sur un phénomène particulier c'est que
la situation de l'emploi des jeunes sur
lesines était structurellement meilleure
qu'ailleurs donc sur une dégradation on
est on a une dégradation plus importante
que d'autres départements ou niveau
Île-de-France
avant de se quitter quelques dates à
noter dans vos agendas la Chambre de
Commerce de Versailles organise deux
formations pour les auto-entrepreneurs
les 19 et 20 septembre à Pontoise et
Versailles le réseau d'appui aux
entreprises BGE propose lui une
formation comptabilité gestion du 24
septembre au 11 octobre à épone et enfin
l'association des femmes créatrices et
chefs d'entreprise de 50 ans en Eveline
les créactives organise une réunion sur
le thème communiqué sur les réseaux
sociaux au porte inité et modalité
vendredi 28 septembre à Montini le
Bretonneux c'est terminé pour ce filcho
consacré au centre commerciaux je vous
retrouve vendredi 28 septembre pour un
nouveau
[Musique]
numéro